All right.
Let's start today with democratic presidential
debate number four, which took place last
night on CNN, a rough roughly
three hour affair.
I did stream commentary for about the first
45 minutes of it before CNN shut it down.
Uh, Sam Cedar's stream getting shut down about
90 minutes in or so according to the tweets
that I got.
Turns out CNN, uh, is much more aggressive
than anybody else when it comes to, uh, preventing
any commentary streams about their debates.
But we have time today to talk about it.
And in general, one would expect that over
time you will have fewer participants in primary
debates.
Although the democratic debates so far sort
of going in the opposite direction after getting
down from 20 to 10 or 11, we were back up
to 12 participants yesterday and it was a
complete and total mess, which was one of
the things that I'll talk about.
I decided I'm not going to play any clips
from the debate in this segment.
Two reasons, really.
One, I want to have more time for commentary
in a three hour debate.
You know, there weren't really these short
moments that lend themselves to highlights
per se.
And in any case there are a whole bunch of,
you know, 1520 minute highlight videos online
and CNN is being so punitive when it comes
to copyright.
We will just be doing my thoughts on it and
uh, you know, check out the clips later.
Widely available online.
So let's talk about that first thing I mentioned.
Once again, debates with 12 people on the
stage aren't good.
That was again confirmed last night and I
don't want to belabor this, but yet again
as if we didn't know, you don't really get
a chance for much depth when you have 12 people
on stage unless you just straight up ignore
some of them for long periods of time, which
actually did also happen yesterday, which
is logical in a sense in that, you know, there's
a big conversation right now on healthcare
for example, between the Bernie Warren view
and the Biden view, which is different but
then also within Bernie Warren because their
positions are also different.
And that was a topic we'll talk about.
And for awhile everybody else was just sort
of ignored.
So it's like I get why they're doing that,
but at the same time, we should just have
fewer people on the stage.
That's what would really make the most sense
now important going in, especially as we get
this far into the primary, we're, the positions
of the candidates are really mostly known.
They may not be known to every voter, but
there aren't really secrets where candidates
have not yet told us their on certain issues.
It's important to understand the context is
one where debates rarely move polling in any
significant way.
And when they do, it's often not permanent.
If it's up, unless you really mess up, in
which case you could do permanent damage to
yourself.
And that's been the theme for the first three
debates.
Example, first debate, the big kill shot that
got a ton of attention and play the next day
was Camila Harris going after Joe Biden.
Uh, that was either the first or second debate.
It got her a spike in the polling immediately,
but then that are roaded over the 10 to 14
days that followed.
And Kamala Harris went right back to where
she was.
So the positive, you know, gotcha moments
only seem to work in the short term with debates
and then things regularize.
Another example, Joe Biden, Joe Biden has
had terrible debates, mostly his first and
second, the third one.
He was rather the first and third were not
very good in the second one, he actually did
okay because he was just attacked even in
irrational ways that made him look like a
martyr, quite frankly.
And he ended up doing okay in that debate.
Um, Joe Biden has generally performed poorly
and he has had a permanent decline in the
polls.
So again, case in point, the debates tend
not to permanently move polling very much
unless you do poorly.
So what I was interested in watching was going
to be number one, does Bernie Sanders go after
Elizabeth Warren?
We talked about the mathematical complexities
of how does Bernie get back into the running
for being in first place.
He's now pretty significantly behind both
Elizabeth Warren and Joe Biden and the complexities
mathematically are that the people that Bernie
could attack, both Biden and Warren, they're
supporters prefer.
In other words, Biden's supporters prefer
Warren over Bernie and Warren supporters prefer
Biden over Bernie, so by attacking them, it's
not clear that Bernie actually helps himself.
So this was a question, does Bernie go after
Warren and we'll talk about that.
I tweeted yesterday that he likely wouldn't.
I said that the more likely scenario was that
Bernie would draw some mild distinctions from
Warren, but that nothing would really change
and this is basically how it went and we'll
get more into that momentarily.
Another element I was watching for, does Joe
Biden seem more energized, not an analysis
of his policy, but does he seem this shrunken,
slowed down Biden or does he seem more energized?
He was more energized to some degree last
night compared to his just terrible prior
performances.
Unclear that it will change very much.
Elizabeth Warren, who now has almost [inaudible]
front runner status with Biden was definitely
more of a target, a number of people on stage
going after her, the focus of more attacks
and disagreements, which we'll get to.
She weathered some of them.
Okay.
Less well with others including questions
around healthcare.
And I'll get to that.
We also wanted to pay attention to how do
other candidates go after or not go after
Biden on the Hunter Biden stuff.
Right.
Even if you don't believe the conspiracy theory
that is being parroted by Trump and the people
around him regarding Joe Biden and Ukraine
and that's all it is, a conspiracy theory
without evidence, you can still be critical
of that $50,000 a month consulting position
that Hunter Biden had with the Ukrainian gas
company.
And there was a question as to how would the
other candidates go after Biden for that.
The answer was not that much.
There really wasn't that much discussion about
it.
Biden did get asked about it.
His response was pretty pathetically wishy
washy and muddled and uninspiring basically
changing the subject and not really addressing
it.
Uh, and that was mostly that foreign policy.
Foreign policy has been a weak point, not
just in the debates, but it's a weak point
for many of the candidates who don't really
demonstrate, I don't want to say they don't
have the knowledge because they may have it
somewhere in there, but they've not demonstrated
deep knowledge on foreign policy.
Does anyone actually propose prescriptions
on foreign policy instead of just criticizing
Trump?
There wasn't that much.
The most discussed foreign policy topic yesterday
with Syria and the Kurds, understandably,
almost everybody on the stage was against
the haphazard withdrawal, or at least the
way that Trump did it.
They were opposed to Tulsi.
Gabard sort of waffled on it.
We know that this is her position.
She took a position that the entire problem
is not Trump withdrawing.
It's regime change Wars and endless Wars,
which is a major problem with American foreign
policy, but it's myopic and simplistic when
it comes to this particular issue as well,
but that's been her talking point on most
foreign policy issues.
She staked that out.
There's a slice of the left that likes it,
and right now it's gotten her 0.8% support
from democratic primary voters.
But other than that, either disagreement with
the way the withdrawal was done or with the
withdrawal, uh, a period the other candidates
did take the opportunity to distance themselves
from Tulsi gabardine position.
P booted.
Judge Frisch, for example, said that she's
just straight up wrong about it.
Uh, but it was a relatively small part of
the debate of the first question.
They made the right decision because there
were 12 people on stage to skip opening statements,
which I loved.
They made the wrong decision to open the debate
with a question about what do you think about
impeachment, which was a complete waste of
time.
Basically, everybody's for impeachment, Tulsi
Gabard not really for it.
Pete booted, judge a little worried about
what the consequences may be, but we knew
that nothing useful was learned from that
question.
It took up about 20 minutes or more.
It provided an opportunity for some of the
candidates to grand stand and it was really,
really lame.
Speaking of lame and cringe-worthy billionaire
Tom Stier who effectively bought his way into
the debate was totally cringe-worthy.
His first opportunity to speak.
He tried, he went directly to an applause
line where the audience of course has been
told basically to shut the F up and not make
noise and very few people reacted and it was
just downhill from there for Tom Stier contributing
nothing.
His presence was totally superfluous in every
way and unfortunately I believe he's qualified
for the fifth debate.
Elizabeth Warren had a particularly weak moment
last night and it was when she was answering
the question, will taxes go up under your
healthcare plan?
I don't want to repeat myself again and again
and again, but I've already addressed many
times a variety of ways in which candidates
could answer this question and she unfortunately
repeated some of the same talking points multiple
times, including some version of, I will not
sign a bill into law that doesn't lower costs
for middle class families.
Sort of a strange double negative.
And really the answer is, I mean, listen,
we know what the answer is.
You have total healthcare costs.
Taxes are a component of a single payer plan,
but in total costs will go down.
Bernie actually handled this pretty well yesterday.
Bernie has also totally missed the Mark on
this question.
Bernie said in clear terms, total costs will
go down.
You get rid of copays, you get rid of premiums,
you get rid of co-insurance, all of that stuff.
You add a payroll tax.
It will be mostly, it will be disproportionately
increased for corporations and for the rich.
Mostly everybody will pay a little bit, but
your total costs will go down.
It's the truth and it's a perfectly reasonable
way to do it because people's costs aren't
zero now.
Now there's some conflict about the math of
that statement in terms of some of the claims
Bernie has made, and that's okay.
We're figuring it out.
But uh, in the end, Bernie messaged that way
better last night and Elizabeth Warren fell
short and she was vulnerable as a result of
it and multiple candidates saying, why can't
you just answer the question, not her best
moment last night.
And what was overall a pretty good performance?
Andrew yangs, Andrew Yang's performance, Andrew
Yang's followers have been tweeting to me
saying, Andrew Yang destroyed it.
He's about to break into the top three now.
I didn't really see it that way.
Andrew Yang did go after Elizabeth Warren
for not adopting his thousand dollar a month
universal basic income proposal.
She said, well, I want to increase social
security payments.
It was a nice attempt by Andrew Yang to, uh,
get some FaceTime with the presumptive co
front runner at this point.
Elizabeth Warren, I don't think it's going
to make much of an impression or impact polling.
Bernie's health came up, of course, having
a heart attack a couple of weeks ago.
Bernie handled it as well as you can while
standing up on a stage and claiming that you're
fine.
Uh, his voice and his energy seemed basically
back to normal.
So that was good.
I don't think he did any damage to himself
when that topic came up.
Uh, Covell Harris brought another one of her
gotcha attempts when she asked Elizabeth Warren,
will you join me in calling for Trump to be
banned on Twitter?
And Warren said, no.
And it was sort of an anticlimactic gotcha
moment.
Harris tried to be shocked.
No you won't, but it was a pretty weak gotcha
attempt.
There's way bigger fish to fry and Camila
Harris has effectively done, unless like in
the next month she can double her support
from, you know, 5% to 10% the last question
of the night was also a throwaway.
Tell us about a surprising friendship that
you have with someone.
Real waste of time, and I know some people
in my audience will say, no, no.
Here's why.
That was actually an interesting question.
It was a waste of time.
I want to hear about policy overall takeaways.
Another dog and pony show components.
A big part of it, relatively few new policy
details were discussed.
I don't expect any big changes in polling
except Bernie looking generally healthy might
help him recover a little bit of what he's
lost in the last couple of weeks.
Biden's seeming slightly higher energy.
Maybe we'll help him recover a little bit
as well.
No one really failed, but the people that
are polling, you know, Z one to 2%, I don't
see that they're going to be doing any better
as a result of this debate.
Uh, Bernie did pretty well with the questions.
He was given Biden, again, given that Biden
is the sort of slowed down Biden, he did pretty
well given the questions he was given.
Although he fumbled when he was asked about
the Hunter Biden thing.
Uh, obviously Biden supporters won't like
the content of what Bernie said.
Bernie supporters won't like the content of
what Biden said, but they both did well enough
to not do damage the candidates.
I thought overall sounded more, um, rehearsed
and less genuine than in prior debates as
if they're now being guided more by polling
and calculated politics.
Sadly, although very often that's where it
gets to at this point in the race.
Bottom line is that we can't keep having 12
people on the stage.
It's just terrible.
I mean, what does Amy Klobuchar think about
impeachment?
What does Julio on Castro think about Syria?
What, what, why is Tulsi Gabbert not fully
behind impeachment?
I mean it's like who cares?
Right?
They have no chance and I want to get into
depth with the people that do have a shot.
A fifth debate is on November 20th the new
qualification requirements are 3% in four
or more approved polls or 5% in two or more
early primary state polls and 165,000 donations.
Now, as of right now, we are like a full month
out from that next debate.
There are already eight people qualified for
that debate, so we may end up again with 10
people just not conducive to good conversation.
Right now the people qualified for debate
number five are Biden, Sanders, Warren Harris,
Buddha, judge Tom Stier.
Again, Andrew Yang and Cory Booker, so we
already are going to have eight people on
stage.
Last thing, I continue to be generally concerned
about the idolatry of politicians.
It's not just Tulsi and yang.
There are, you know, Bernie idolaters, Warren
idolaters from the tweets that I'm getting.
When I asked for feedback about the Bates
or polling or whatever on Twitter, people
just as a few Civ about some of these candidates
as if these are saviors or near deities and
my position is politicians just aren't the
best period.
These aren't, I would argue even the types
of people that we should be idolizing and
without commenting on any specific politicians,
I would just want to see sort of more measured
analysis than the gushing praise of pseudo
deities that I'm seeing on Twitter about certain
candidates.
That's just me.
I just don't see politicians in the same light.
Maybe it's because I do this show and I've
met a lot of these people and it's like these
are just imperfect people with many flaws
and sometimes they have good ideas on a few
issues, but I want to hear from you about
that.
I want to hear from you about the debate.
If you're watching on YouTube, please leave
a response down below or send me a tweet at
deep Pacman.
I do want to hear from you.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter.
We will take a quick break and be back
with all the day's news right after this